if you're a millionaire why sell course
okay
hi today we're talking about filters
this is episode two we're just gonna
call the last video episode one even
though I meant it as a one-off I just
kept finding these fake gurus and I
decided to dedicate a series to these
people that seem to be everywhere on the
Internet and I can't it just makes me so
angry
watching these people scam people out of
their money because that make no mistake
that is what Ricky Gutierrez is doing so
let's uh let's hop into what he's what
what he's doing when he's 69 they were
given to my other stream that natural
gas is continuously get it right ciao
I'm in a little bit over okay so he's a
day trader and he's gonna teach you how
to day trade that's his whole shtick so
so why am i set up set about this by the
way he's got a really loyal following so
if you guys are a fan of Ricky Gutierrez
you're listening to this
don't write a comment just yet just
consider for a second if he's actually
lying about this stuff and he's he's
asking you to pay money for a course
which we'll get to in a second is that
wrong is it wrong to lie about something
and then sell a course about something
you've lied about I I think it is so I'm
gonna try to demonstrate that and then
if at the end of the video you think
that I haven't done done a good enough
job then you can post your comment but I
ask you to withhold your thoughts for
just one second okay so let's talk about
Ricky's claims okay Ricky is a day
trader teacher basically you can buy a
course called learn print plan learn
plan profit and he's also got a like
free Facebook Facebook group that
operates sort of as a sales funnel into
the learn plan profit which is this
private course okay so let's talk about
what you can expect from where the plan
profit and and sort of under Ricky's
tutelage what you can expect to make
just to get right into it the goal one
hundred dollars a day five thousand
dollars to make a hundred dollars a day
that's a goal of 2% growth daily okay so
here's where he's like setting up this
this hypothetical
and here's where he's gonna say like oh
actually I think this is aggressive he's
constantly saying what a conservative
investor yes okay so we'll get to that
right can probably aim for a $100 a day
goal when it comes down to my approach
I'm much more conservative meaning that
I like to be very realistic when it
comes down to setting goals for myself
okay so that's that's that's key
Ricky calls himself a conservative
investor and to be clear 2% return daily
is insanely aggressive okay but it gets
a little confusing when we talk about
what Ricky sees as conservative how
important it is to set realistic goals
do I think that you should actually set
a goal of 2% a day probably not a one to
one-and-a-half percent goal I think it's
much more realistic you know okay he
just said a one to one and a half
percent goal is a realistic benchmark
for one of his students to hit when
they're starting out with like let's say
a principal of five thousand they should
be able to hit a one percent daily goal
one to one and a half percent now let's
talk about what that actually means okay
so like let's say let's say I set up
like a little sample thing don't get
confused I'll explain it this is what
you're starting with this is what your
daily growth is here's your days and
then here's what you have at the end of
each day okay and then this is your
annualized return what you're making
over the year what's what's really
important is just to know what what he's
actually proposing is a realistic it's a
realistic goal so let's do let's do one
percent right let's just say
conservative let's be conservative with
Ricky and say you can make one percent
every single day day true that's a
conservative estimate okay so let's see
what we have all our returns are really
good by the end of 365 days if you can
do that you have taken your money from
$5,000 to now you own you have a hundred
eighty eight thousand dollars in one
year okay
Ricky says that's conservative I would
say that's insane and impossible that is
an annualized return of 365 percent
let's put that into perspective the
average return of the S&P 500 the an
index fund a great index fund that the
average return is nine point eight
percent over the last 90 years for 2017
it was nine point seven percent it
hovers around that seven to ten percent
range okay
Ricky is telling you that two percent
daily is way too way too extreme but one
percent is a conservative estimate that
is bonkers if you could make one percent
every day with even five thousand
dollars every single hedge fund on Wall
Street would be beating down your doors
to try to find out your special sauce
okay that's just a fact if we consider
that the SP makes nine percent per year
and that means that the SP is making 40
times less money than a conservative
estimate by Ricky to be clear this is
what Ricky calls a conservative
achievable goal by someone who trades in
penny stocks to be very clear or stocks
and in general using his tactic
consistently making 40 times what the SP
500 makes I mean it's absolutely
ridiculous the claims that he's making
and by the way the thing is is that he's
not backing these up with facts
where are the broker statements where is
the proof if you're gonna say that
you're making that you're your students
can make 40 percent 40 40 times what the
SP 500 is producing if you're gonna say
that you're making this much times more
than what the SP 500 is making where's
the evidence where the broker statements
he has yet to produce a broker statement
and the reason for that is because there
are none it is a fraud and look I know
what you're thinking if he's saying
goals he doesn't mean that you can hit
this consistently he's obviously saying
this is should be your target not what
you're gonna hit every
there's no way this guy says you can do
this consistently right again we're
trying to talk about $100 a day
consistently consistently he is actually
meaning 1% consistently every day not
just from time to time not just from
time to time no no no with Ricki it's
consistent my goal on a weekly basis is
10 to 15 percent and I've been doing
this for years yeah I normally trade
with about $25,000 so that means my
average is about $2,500 in return on a
weekly basis okay so he does tend to
follow much so you know let's say just
10% over what 7 so he is averaging 1.4
3% growth so he's looking at 500% return
so Ricky is telling you that he makes a
consistent a consistent 1.4 3% growth
because he averages 10 to 15% which
means he gets 500% if you believe that
I've got a bridge to sell you the great
Warren Buffett the grip the person
people point to to say that no you can
indeed beat the market consistently has
only been able to double the SMP 500
he's gotten a yearly average return of
21% which is incredible and he should go
down in the history books for that
actually Warren's not as good as we all
thought actually Ricky's doing 24 times
better than Warren that's how much
better
Ricky be Warren is so just to give you
an idea and look you might be asking
yourself why are you spending time on
this guy like debunking them okay the
problem is is he's preying on the
dunning-kruger effect of when people are
bad at investing in stocks okay
the dunning-kruger effect has effect is
when you're unskilled and unaware of it
you have trouble recognizing the fact
that you don't know anything and so when
Ricky comes in and he talks about these
these great returns you're gonna have or
you know the the resistance line of the
support line and all these chart metrics
people just buy into it and they think
oh I'm actually getting good at
something their confidence is going up
when in reality they don't see ahead of
them that they're they're just they're a
total beginner and a total amateur and
the things that Ricky is saying you can
do with this advice that he's giving is
untrue there is no consistent way to
beat the market and so any claim that
Ricky's making that he has some
consistent strategy is just false you
might be telling yourself maybe he's
just a lucky guy and maybe he is smarter
than the rest of us you know give him
the benefit of doubt why would he lie to
me why would he lie to me well because
he's profiting from lying to you
so Ricky runs a course called learn plan
profit he charges $300 for his lessons
and he says let's see what he says in
the learning plan profit thing because
let's see what his claims are in the
next 45 seconds I will show you how I've
taught over 60,000 of our members to
trade in the stock market successfully
it's okay that's the thing that's why
I'm making this video he's saying he's
teaching thousands of traders to achieve
consistent growth in the stock market
with his approach that's absolutely
wrong
he's never produced any brokerage
statement that's proved that he's made
the returns he says he's made and and
those are the things he's promising to
give you I mean he's building his whole
course on the fact that he's this super
successful trader with five hundred
percent returns
um he's I mean he said it I didn't say
he's saying he's consistently making ten
to fifteen percent weekly that's five
hundred percent yearly buddy where is
the proof where is the proof and by the
way my favorite part is that Ricky can't
seem to understand that why anyone who
hate him he's absolutely baffled why
anyone would hate him one of the one of
my biggest like pet peeves and it's just
something that I'm not comfortable
it's something that I've never been
comfortable but but people like go out
of the way to try to discredit me
because I sell of course because other
people have been you know scams that
they think automatically because I'm
young because I invest in the stock
market and because I show my sports cars
that it's a champ no no no no Ricky
people think it's a scam because you're
promising returns that Arthur what what
24 times Warren Buffett's returns that's
why they're calling you a scam it's not
because of your cars and it's not
because you're young and it's not
because you did well in the stock market
you know you should you got some
learning to do but you need to open your
ears up a little bit right people will
automatically try to discredit you when
they see someone doing well no no no
people will discredit you when you make
claims that are not true to profit off
people who can't afford it and this is
the thing is like Ricky can't seem to
get the fact that if you were a
millionaire and you could make these
insane returns consistently like he says
he could then you'd have no need to sell
a course and laughs Andrew Hales has it
a hilarious interview with this guy
where he tries to get to this question
and and he never gets an answer yeah I
don't know what I want I want your
opinion like what do you think about
courses common sense would say like if
you're a millionaire and you're doing
greater than why bother some of course
exactly okay
what's your response okay so I was
someone that like if you were I don't
want to go over his whole his whole
interview I just want to show you where
we're law or Andrew Hales keeps
questioning why this guy would would not
offer well it for freedom girls cars on
his instances all that I got your page
where the where it looks like every
other like get-rich-quick thing you know
100 percent so like if you were to and
you consistently profit consistently
profit I mean has he been called a fraud
a 100 percent okay Ricky yeah in three
sentences
or less if you're a millionaire why sell
course okay I'm leaking the interview in
the description so if you want you can
go watch Ricki try to stutter through an
answer on this one he just tries to beat
around the bush and there is not there
isn't a great answer because the truth
is there is no good reason to make a 300
dollar course if you could make 500%
returns which is what Rickey is saying
he's making that is your fake guru of
the week people stay away from him Ricky
Gutierrez just a waste of money you know
a waste of money and a waste of your
time because you shouldn't learn from
anybody who's lying and yes I'm saying
he's lying I I know that seems kind of
harsh because we don't have any direct
evidence that he's not making 500% a
year but I I feel pretty confident I
feel pretty confident that all that all
Ricky's not making 500% with Renaissance
Technologies only making 70% with Warren
Buffett only making 20% a year I feel
like the odds are in my favor on this
one have a good week folks
[Music]